I heard you saying over there that you
consider yourself to be the best player
in the draft does it bug you that it
always seems like it's it's got to be a
quarterback who's the number one pick no
matter what the other guys can do no you
notice no that's just what it is it's
what no always has but I felt like you
know if you look at my field from the
deepest of standpoint the way I can take
over game I feel like you know in
college football you haven't seen a lot
of people that can tell you again like I
had you know I felt like you know my
tape just speaks to it me being the best
manager chase young Ohio State pass
rusher and one of the budding superstars
who I think would agree because I had a
conversation with him about this he
would agree with me that none of this is
an honor none of it is a privilege it's
a privilege oh you're crazy
and it will be I'm telling you I've had
the conversation with him he gets it
it's not an honor for a team to want him
it's an honor for a team to get his
services and for a team to have him on
the roster because he's special and you
know he's special because he I assume is
your job edge rusher for the draft
tell me about well yes I mean upon what
you've seen from him yeah you're right
well I mean he is special I mean they're
just you know again like one of my
favorite lines with people like this
there's just not a whole lot of people
walking around planet earth that are
built the way chase young is and then
can move and explode off the line of
scrimmage the way he does at a 265
pounds the strength he has he's got the
strength of a 300 pound defense at end I
mean there's really no weakness to his
game as far as physical traits are
concerned and then you go oh there's a
rawness here still to his game to where
he can improve right he's not as well
schooled of a pass rusher as like Nick
Bosa was coming out last year but I
think he's an overall better athletic
specimen than a nick Bosa and that's
what's awesome when you have an athletic
specimen that's special a guy that has
all the physical traits to be special to
continue to add to that and then has
room to grow and a coach can mould him a
little bit that's where he's special and
yes Mike I mean he's slam dunk you know
from what I've seen yes he is he's
probably the best player in the draft at
this point I don't disagree with what
Jayceon they said yeah and I'll tell you
what some
he's gonna end up with a great great
player they just keep manufacturing at
Ohio State University yes they do
players now they're attracting them but
they are turning them into dominant
forces and especially along the
defensive line and chase young is going
to be a difference maker as a rookie and
it was great to talk to him at the
Scouting Combine that was just a week or
so before the world turned upside down
due to the corona virus pandemic K LaVon
Chaisson of LSU a very colorful
personality a guy that I spoke to as
well back when you were on the injured
reserve list with whatever it was that
you had it was Corona I'm still hoping I
want to get the antibody test I really
am I'm hoping it was that and I got it
out of my system I don't know but it's
re he's he's number two on your list how
big of a gap do you see between young
and Chaisson I you know I don't think
it's as big a gap is what I see just as
far as mock drafts and things like that
Mike Kaleb on Chaisson is one of my
favorite players in the draft he is the
most naturally gifted pass rusher in the
draft and you know I say that I mean
when you talk about exploding off the
line of scrimmage
being able to bend around the corner
like the great ones like a Lawrence
Taylor a Von Miller you know a Derrick
Thomas he has some of those body
movements that are very special along
with being really physical and strong
for a guy that's you know not gigantic
63 to 56 around there but Mike this was
one of my favorite watches in the whole
draft I think this guy's kind of being
underappreciated a little bit as as far
as you know the love he's getting I
think listen my rationale would be this
you know I love Brian burns last year he
was a top he was the number 15 pick for
the Carolina Panthers Vic Beasley was
the number seven pick for the Atlanta
Falcons coming out of Clemson came Levon
Chaisson is a top 15 talent there's no
doubt about it I would sit here and
argue he's a top 10 talent I think he's
a really special pass rusher you saw the
personality I hear great things about
that he wore 18 at LSU which means he's
you know one of their great leaders of
their football team so that speaks to
what he is off the field but man Mike
Talon wise this is one of my man crushes
of the draft and you know what he has
great
great pair of mic his legs and butt are
special which is why he can run around
the corner running for four with a
300-pounder on his back and still get to
the quarterback yeah I I it's me what
they look like in person
those two guys mic just when you saw
Caleb on chase on and chase young I'm so
disappointed I didn't get to see more of
them and be closer I was like in the
room with them at one point but never
got to get really close what was your
take of just how they were built and
what they look like well I mean when
when they're in the room of hard there
were baggy clothes wearing the same
underwear that you see during the
workouts so you know I'm more focused on
having a conversation with the guys not
putting my giant meathook hand on their
leg to see how big it is like you would
have done yes say I gotta get a little
touch and feel in there just to make
sure what the muscle density is but it's
a it's a good group okay as far as pass
rushers there's a little more depth of
the position as far as the edge pass
rushers there's a few other guys here
had the ajm' vanessa kid from iowa he
had an underwhelming combine but man
mike when i watch him play he's not a
sexy sax sack machine type but he's a
guy that's a strong side defense n the
guy who can take on the tight end tackle
double team and certainly have enough
strength to handle a tackle one-on-one
and do things like that you know this is
a really good football player in theory
he could be like a Michael Bennett or a
Tyrone Crawford for the Dallas Cowboys
play defense to end on first and second
down probably move inside on third down
and be a mismatch for Garden in the
passing game so he's a really good
player too who I think is a first round
player his numbers of the combine don't
show that
but his play on the field and film shows
he's more explosive than what the
combine numbers were and he's very
disruptive and makes a whole lot of
plays so you know I look at him as being
a guy who has New England written all
over him I feel like he's that type of
player that could do multiple things for
that Belichick defense in the front
seven and the bottom line is the most
important positions for an NFL team
continue to be quarterback and guy who
chases quarterback definitely it and
every once in a while we kind
forget the value of a great pass rush
until a great pass rush carries a team
to a championship and they were like oh
yeah probably a good idea to have a
great pass rush but I think most most
teams most teams remember that all the
time Chris yes Mike well I mean that's
that's the the predicament I'm sure the
Washington Redskins are in a little bit
right now hey it's the number-two pick
I'm sure there's some teams that are
interested in chase young or other
appliers that are in the draft that they
might want to trade up for and the
Redskins who have three first-round d
lineman on their front line already now
they can add chase young and you know if
you're them Mike what do you do do you
just go and go hey I'm gonna all right
I'm gonna have four just super freaks on
the defensive line and we're gonna win
some games with that you know or you
know would you trade down I wouldn't I
wouldn't pass up the opportunity to take
chase young and have him opposite of
Montez sweat or Ryan Kerrigan and then
the two Alabama boys in the middle so
that'll be an interesting thing to watch
for in the draft especially if there's
some clamoring for the quarterback you
know jockeying for that position with
Herbert you know maybe Tula who I don't
think certain you know me I don't think
it's worth the number two pick or a top
ten pick in my opinion but it'll be
interesting to see if there's some
action there for that spot when all said
and done but I'm man Mike I love this
Caleb on Chaisson he's my fit one of my
favorite guys in the draft
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports